my name is Jonathan mcpadden and I'm
here to show you more make files as I
scrunch on chips all right this is part
2 what we have here is we have a new
concept it deviates from all the world
and is called guess guess what are these
called doesn't help you remember guess
good macros if you'd make them equal to
something and anytime you call the macro
it does whatever is on the right side
and you can chain them like so like so
this runs whatever that is so this is a
make file I made I call it the best make
file for CPP I don't know if it's the
best it probably it's my favorite one
but it's cool because it does everything
for you you just got it use it let allow
me to explain how it does everything for
you so say you're running a C++ thing
alright just hypothetical and you got a
folder where you want your stuff to
reside all your stuff you put this make
file in there you make a source
directory you put all your your source
files on there CPP files headers
whatever you want this looks at every
CPP file in that folder and it builds
builds all those into objects and it
turns those objects into a final target
which sits on the root directory still
confused just just go to this and look
at the readme ok
there you go you want to grab this you
can go to raw and in Linux type W get
and then this you know download it to
your current directory okay let me to
demonstrate W get this whoa what just
happened W get this whole thing how do
you paste in this I don't know okay
control shift insert there we go
ready for what happens next it did it
when goes LS and it's not there missing
what didn't well I'm gonna have to cut
this part of the video now there we go
so I needed I need the - n - n means
download if it's new I might have had
some some bad data in there from all the
random hotkey suppressed okay so yeah W
get - in that boom you got it now we can
LS see it and same one so big yeah you
can edit this if you what you can you
can change stuff if you want for your
project there you go
make files part 2 in the next video how
to use your make file with an IDE where
you can just press like play and build
and it does all the stuff when you make
file for you I'm gonna specifically look
at cute creator because it's the one
I've been using recently and you can do
it you can just take a make file like
this and have it be your project build
and run and all that stuff just with
their little little natural buttons All
Right see ya don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and